[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
a father pleads for answers in his
daughter's disappearance whatever you
can do to make sure my daughter comes
home
i'm asking for that help plus the new
body cam video taken just days before
gabrielle petitto disappeared and alec
murdoch behind bars the prominent lawyer
admitting his involvement in a botch
assisted suicide plot plus an exonerated
attorney working to make change we are
simply trying to redeem justice in our
justice system jared adams gives us his
take on the rodney reed case and later
requires that the aurora police
department change in meaningful ways so
that no more lives are lost racially
biased policing found after the death of
elijah mclean what officials say must be
changed in aurora colorado law and crime
daily covering court cases from coast to
coast
[Music]
welcome i everyone to law and crime
daily i'm brian buckmeyer along with
terry austin we begin with shocking new
body camera video that may be the last
video taken of gabriella potito before
she vanished without a trace after a
road trip with her fiance
the video came to light as police
officers and potido's parents asked
anyone with information about her
disappearance to come forward
well we share the frustration with with
the world right now so you know
two people went on a trip one person
returned and that person that returned
isn't providing us any information 22
year old petito was reported missing on
september 11th after her fiance brian
lowdry returned to his family's home in
florida without her laodi drove there in
petito's van back in july the pair left
for a cross-country road trip that was
cut short potito is believed to have
last been seen near grand teton national
park in wyoming two weeks before she
disappeared petito and louji were pulled
over for a domestic disturbance body cam
video shows potato in an emotional state
i don't know we just been fighting all
morning and
and you wouldn't let me in the car
before and then why wouldn't you let you
in the car because you're because you're
going to see me that's why we need to be
calm down
yeah
but i'm perfectly calm i'm gone all the
time and
he really stresses me out and
this is a rough morning police officers
in utah later determined petito had
slapped loudry and that she suffered
from anxiety officers considered it a
mental health crisis not a domestic
abuse incident and helped separate the
couple for the night yes they had a
disturbance yes it was captured on body
camera their interaction with law
enforcement but beyond that you know i
don't know what it has to do with the
disappearance in a press conference
thursday northport police in florida
confirmed they know where loudry is but
that he is not cooperating with the
investigation why does he get the
privilege to tell you no that he's not
coming in to speak to you because the
constitution protects that petito's
father is now speaking out in a plea for
help
i'm asking for help from everyone here
i'm asking for help everyone at home i'm
asking for help from the parents
of
o'brien officials say they're working
with the fbi and police departments in
the western united states to find potito
she's not here
so where is she
joining us today is trial attorney anna
yum and terry hostin
anna and i'm torn laundry's got his
right against self-incrimination the as
the officer said there but this looks
horrible if he was your client i don't
know would you advise him to speak and
get ahead of this or stay
silent well that's an excellent question
it really depends and listen this is a
heartbreaking situation because from a
legal perspective absolutely if you're a
criminal defense attorney your
obligation is to protect your client and
he has a constitutional right against
self-incrimination so if there's a
situation where you're talking to your
client and your client potentially is
implicated then of course if you're the
criminal defense attorney you have to
advise your client to remain silent now
just because he ends up lawyering up
doesn't necessarily mean he's guilty he
has a constitutional right so if you
take your lawyer hat off though and if
you take your criminal defense attorney
hat off and if you just think of it from
a public opinion perspective and of
course uh her family has every right to
want answers and to have answers as to
why she didn't come back and why he came
back alone so it is a very tough
question in a very fine line absolutely
terry we've seen a dozen of these
missing persons cases how do you think
investigators will go about finding
gabby petito
this case is all about forensics brian
there's no question they're going to
look into that white van they've already
said they have the van they're searching
it they're getting evidence from the van
and they're going to figure out what was
in that van before she disappeared
they're also going to look at cell phone
records and try to figure out where each
of them was before that disappearance
and i think the fact that they're
coordinating with the fbi and local
authorities is very important that gives
them far more resources than they would
have if they were just looking at this
individually but really brian they have
to follow what's going on with laundry
i'm assuming they might be even
recording his records so we'll see what
happens absolutely definitely checking
not only like you said the cell phones
maybe the cell phones were traveling
together maybe they were separate that's
something that i'm very interested to
see and see how this plays out all
together thank you both
the father of a family accused of
killing another family appears in court
days after his wife agrees to testify
against him
billy wagner is accused in the 2016
execution-style murders of eight members
of the rodent and gilly families in pike
county ohio just last week his wife
angela pled guilty to her role in the
murders and agreed to testify against
her husband and son billy and angela's
son jake pled guilty earlier this year
billy's attorneys say they just received
copies of jake and angel's confessions
he'll be back in court in november
ex-minnesota police officer derek shovin
enters another not guilty plea to
federal charges that he violated a
teenager's civil rights chauvin appeared
in court thursday via zoom from prison
chauvin faces federal charges stemming
from the incident in 2017. officials say
he repeatedly hit a 14 year old boy over
the head with a flashlight and held him
by the neck earlier in the week shoving
appeared in federal court for other
charges stemming from the 2020 death of
george floyd chauvin and three other
ex-officers two tao jay alexander king
and thomas lane face charges of
depriving floyd of his constitutional
rights in june shoving was sentenced to
22 and a half years in prison for
floyd's murder
testimony in the federal trial of
elizabeth holmes reveals her blood
testing company wasn't using human blood
samples in his quality control test
holmes was ceo of the now defunct
theranos a company she claimed would
revolutionize blood testing but as
witnesses explained on wednesday there
were many problems with the testing
units oftentimes they said the tests
wouldn't produce the same outcome twice
and were unreliable the former
billionaire faces 12 fraud charges in
connection to her time with theranos her
child expects to last for weeks
and the prosecution is preparing to rest
soon in r kelly's sex trafficking and
racketeering case testimony has been
ongoing for nearly a month with several
accusers taking the stand to testify
about r kelly's alleged abuse a judge
recently admitted tapes dating back to
2008 that include recordings of the r b
singer screaming and then assaulting a
woman who allegedly lied to him the jury
has listened to these tapes but due to
lack of cameras in federal courtroom
it's unclear what their reactions were
to these recordings court was dark on
thursday but testimony is set to resume
on friday where it is expected that the
government will rest their case
still ahead on law and crime daily a
verdict could be coming in robert
durst's murder trial
but first a prominent south carolina
lawyer admits to hiring a hitman to
carry out his own murder what's next for
alec murdoch
[Music]
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live one
crime network with youtube tv for all of
your daily live trial coverage legal
news expert analysis and original true
crime programs subscribe to youtube tv
today and then locate law and crime in
the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle watch lawn crime every day with
youtube tv we put you in the jury box
[Music]
welcome back prominent south carolina
attorney alec murdoch turns himself in
on charges related to an unbelievable
plot to kill himself
in a story that the law and crime
network has been following for weeks
murdoch says he hired a former client to
shoot and kill him so his son could
collect a 10 million dollar life
insurance payout on thursday murder was
arrested and booked into the hampton
county detention center in south
carolina murda was shot in the head on
september 4 but survived earlier this
week 61-year-old curtis edward smith was
arrested in connection to the shooting
in an exclusive interview courtesy of
the today show murdo's attorney claims
this plot was unrelated to the deaths of
his wife and son both were found
murdered at their home in june
let's talk about megan paul her dick
because your client lied about the
circumstances under which he was shot
it wouldn't be a stretch for folks to
think that he probably also lied about
the circumstances under which his wife
and son were shot
well that that and i look i've spent the
last year and a half with maggie and
paul and alec i represented paul on the
boat case um met with them dozens of
times uh they were very affectionate
they maggie and paul
and alec all together uh paul and i mean
maggie and alec holding hands he is
totally distraught we've talked to him
at length about it this week
clearly he is distraught about their
death but he did not murder them
no alec has released on a twenty
thousand dollar uh personal
reconnaissance bail and had his passport
surrendered but let's bring in trial
attorney anna young and co-host terry
austin to discuss more terry with
authorities knowing that murder is
capable of a murder for higher plot do
you think this will cause them to
reevaluate not only the death of his
wife and son but also these previous
murders
no doubt about it brian where there is
smoke there is fire his wife who was
only 52 his son who was only 22 were
both found shot and killed they don't
know what
happened with that or whether he was
involved then of course this bungled
suicide attempt which we don't know much
about yet except we do know the other
individual involved but the housekeeper
who was found dead she tripped and she
fell and that was back in
2018 and it was on their home at the
premises so that was still a little bit
odd and then the boat accident with
mallory beach the 19 year old girl that
was supposedly an accident but now that
all of these people around him are
turning up dead yes it's a problem
they're going to look into it a lot of
questions and a few answers is yet anna
murdo's charges insurance fraud
conspiracy to commit insurance fraud and
filing a false report doesn't really
sound like a murder for hire could there
be more charges coming
you know brian i think that's going to
be a stretch you you talk about the
facts in this case and you're thinking
to yourself geez this is something that
i possibly could have seen in a law
school exam because there's so many
convoluted facts to terry's point and
there's so many different issues that
are coming up i think it's going to be
very difficult for the prosecutor to sit
there and charge him with a murder for
hire or attempted murder of himself how
is that even possible i think that's
going to be extremely hard i think it's
going to be an uphill battle i think
that this evidence is relevant for
purposes of insurance fraud and
conspiracy to commit insurance fraud
things of that nature but in terms of
any kind of murder attempted murder
charges or anything like that i don't
see that happening yeah i think you're
right there are definitely a law school
problem that someone else will have to
figure out i graduated far too long ago
i'm not going to touch that on a 10-foot
pole thank you
and we are officially in verdict watch
in the state of california as the jury
weighs the fate of accused murderer
robert durst
the relay said air is charged with the
2000 murder of his best friend susan
berman she was found in her home shot in
the back of the head prosecutors claimed
durst killed berman because she was
going to give information to authorities
about his wife kathy who went missing in
1982. though a body was never found
prosecutors think durst murdered kathy
the jury heard three months of testimony
durst spent 14 days on the stand the
jurors must consider whether durst is
guilty of killing susan berman because
she was a witness to a crime they asked
to see a timeline of events brought it
up in closing arguments the judge denied
this request since the timeline was not
in evidence
coming up on law and crime daily bias
policing revealed after the death of
elijah mcclain what's next for the
aurora colorado police and fire
departments
but first long crime daily sits down
with attorney jarrod adams how his
wrongful conviction created a drive to
exonerate others in need
[Music]
an exonerated man-turned defense
attorney now works to free other
innocent inmates
in 1998 when he was just 17 years old
jared adams was wrongfully convicted of
sexual assault and sentenced to 28 years
in prison during the nine years that he
served he began to study the law upon
his release he hit the ground running
working to bring fairness to the
criminal justice system his latest case
focuses on death row inmate rodney reed
who was convicted in 1998 of abduction
and rape and murder of stacy stites
reed's dna was found inside stite's body
but he says he had a consensual
relationship with her reed was scheduled
to be executed in 2019 but a permanent
stay was later granted to review his
claim of innocence
as jared adams works to be free read our
very own terry austin sat down with the
exoneree who explains how he plans to
make his mark on the justice system
can you tell us a little bit jared about
your story so we go to a party where we
were accused of a sexual assault um by a
young lady and
with no evidence at all other than
accusation
we were believed to be guilty um and and
you know not giving that presumption of
innocence at all you wrote a book called
redeeming justice tell us what made you
write that book what's the book all
about
i got this law degree
and i kept thinking naively that once i
got this law degree i would be able to
cure all the ills right all of the black
mothers who are sitting there worried to
death about their sons like me and my
mother was i thought that i would have
this law degree and be able to tackle it
all
i learned that this is just it's like
spawning water out of the ocean unless
you have the support of the community
and the the folks in the legal world as
well to move towards what justice
equality and fairness is one of the
people that you helped are currently
helping is rodney reed he was convicted
in 1998 for the murder of stacy seitz i
was fortunate to get employed by the
innocence project as their first
litigation fellow who was exonerated and
simply put without using all of the big
words
this is what i want to say about the
rodney reed case it is extremely
questionable we believe that rodney is
innocent of what he was accused of but
even if those who aren't willing to come
to where we are in rodney's belief
there's no way that you can't agree that
it is so many questions in this case
that man deserves a new trial we try to
take cases
and litigate claims of actual innocence
and through doing so
we try to get the world's legislators
everyone's attention to say this
the criminal justice system is man-made
man makes mistakes but when it comes to
mistakes and lives a case can be
overturned and reversed the damage of
loss of life can never be
turning now to ohio where both sides
rest in an arson murder trial
stanley ford is accused of setting three
fires in his neighborhood two of those
fires resulted in the deaths of nine
people including a family of seven whose
children were all under the age of 15
years old
testimony lasted nine days the defendant
did not testify and the defense elected
not to call any witnesses the last
witness called by the prosecution was
patrick boggs the ex-husband of one of
the victims boggs previously served 12
years in jail for dousing his wife with
kerosene and threatening her with a
lighter boggs was briefly detained for
setting the 2017 fire that resulted in
his ex-wife's death but police later
released him boggs who was in jail for
another domestic violence case appeared
in court on wednesday
do you solemnly swear for him to tell
the truth the whole truth and nothing
but the truth so help you god
go ahead and have a seat mr boggs
and at this time do you choose to
testify i choose fifth complete the
fifth and did not testify at all so
you're choosing to um
invoke your fifth amendment right
against self-incrimination is that
correct yes ma'am so if you were called
to testify any questions you would be
asked you would invoke the fifth
amendment is that correct yes and you
would choose not to answer any questions
yes ma'am
when we come back a civil rights
investigation in the city where elijah
mcclain was killed what the colorado
attorney general has to say about what
the investigation revealed
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily
following the death of elijah mcclain a
civil rights investigation into the
aurora police and fire department found
that there was a pattern and practice of
racially biased policing and excessive
force
investigators reviewed more than 3
million records about 3000 police
reports and analyzed internal data from
the aurora police department and fire
and rescue department the investigation
found officers would apply more force
than was needed without giving people
the time to respond to commands attorney
general phil wieser says these failures
are systemic and show severe cultural
challenges created by the department's
police culture flawed discipline
challenges and hiring issues in a
statement a.j weisser said these actions
quote hurt the people the law
enforcement is entrusted to protect and
destroy community trust now weisser is
calling for culture and leadership
changes to police and fire departments
i sat down with mari newman who
represents elijah mclean's family as the
investigation was ongoing and got her
thoughts about the probe
to the rural police department which as
you and i discussed last time has a
long-standing and horrible uh pattern of
both racism and brutality that has gone
on for decades i've been suing them for
decades and surely
it began long before that and so that
investigation is also ongoing and my
hope is that that will result ultimately
in a consent decree which requires that
the aurora police department change in
meaningful ways so that no more lives
are lost
can the results of this probe be used in
the criminal case or civil case
involving elijah mcclane and if so how
well i think in a similar case it
possibly can just to show that there's a
pattern in practice because remember in
a civil case it's all about damages it's
all about the money you know whether the
city or the aurora police department is
liable or responsible so i can easily
see this kind of information being
showcased in a civil trial in a criminal
trial not as much i don't i don't think
that that would necessarily happen and
if i'm the criminal defense attorney i'm
fighting like crazy to try to keep that
out because in a criminal case it's not
about damages it's not about money it's
about whether the government can prove
that a person committed a crime on a
particular day so unless there's footage
to show that these particular officers
engaged in that type of behavior before
i would argue that that causal nexus is
not there and so of course i would be
arguing to keep that out i'd agree there
whole harley on both points both civil
and criminal aspect terry the death of
elijah mclean appears to have uncovered
serious problems in aurora colorado
should we expect the doj to follow up
with federal charges
brian i think the federal doj will wait
and see what happens on the state level
i think attorney general in colorado
found this pattern of practice and did a
thorough investigation it's really one
of the first kinds of this type of
investigation in colorado and there also
is a police reform bill in colorado and
under that reform bill the agency who
was accused actually has 60 days to
implement the changes and we know that
the attorney general had multiple
changes that he wanted to see done in
the state and if in fact the agencies
take the time and the effort to change
their policies to implement the changes
i don't think that we'll see federal
action i agree as well but we'll see how
it plays out thank you for joining us
here on law and crime daily we'll see
you next time as we discuss justice in
america
[Music]
[Music]
you